Female mosquitoes can put a damper on any
outdoor event when they start to snack on
those present.
(Note: only the females drink your blood;
they don’t need it for their own nourishment,
but for certain nutrients necessary to develop
their eggs).
Certain people seem to be swatting the insects
away or ending the night with more red bites
than others.
So is it true that some people really are
more “attractive” to mosquitoes, and,
if so, why is this the case?
To answer the first question- yes, some people
do attract mosquitoes more than others at
certain times.
As for the answer to why this is the case,
there are numerous factors involved.
Beyond the several hundred chemical odors
that have been identified to date that the
human body gives off (some of which singularly,
or in combination with others, attract or
repel mosquitoes), there are also over 3500
types of mosquitoes, not all of which are
attracted to or are repelled by the same things.
Needless to say, why mosquitoes seem to be
more attracted to one person over another
at a given time is very difficult to discern.
That said, in general, we know definitively
that seemingly all female mosquitoes identify
you as a potential target for a blood meal
via the carbon dioxide your body puts off,
which they detect via their maxillary palp
organ.
In fact, mosquitoes can detect you this way
from up to about 100-150 ft (~40 meters) away.
This is one of the many reasons mosquitoes
tend to target people who are in the middle
of exercising more- when you’re working
out and breathing hard, you’re giving off
more carbon dioxide than you otherwise would
in your resting state.
This also contributes to overweight or otherwise
larger individuals being more targeted by
mosquitoes than their slimmer or shorter brethren-
the more body mass, the more oxygen the body
needs to maintain it and the more carbon dioxide
the individual will give off.
Essentially, the higher your metabolic rate,
the more carbon dioxide you give off and the
more you’ll be (at least initially) attractive
to female mosquitoes looking for some blood
so they can make baby mosquitoes.
This is also one of the reasons why children
are usually less likely to be bitten by mosquitoes
than adults, and men more likely to be bitten
than women.
Another contributing factor to people exercising
being more likely to be bitten is body heat-
the higher your body heat, the more likely
a mosquito is to notice you.
This is also generally hypothesized to be
a potential reason that people who are drinking
alcohol are more likely to be bitten.
However, it should be noted that it’s a
myth that drinking alcohol raises your body
temperature.
In fact, the opposite happens; the age old
remedy for staving off extreme cold via drinking
alcohol actually makes it more likely you’ll
get hypothermia, as alcohol cools your body
off.
Drinking alcohol does make you feel warmer
because it dilates your blood vessels, particularly
the capillaries under the surface of your
skin.
Thus, the volume of blood brought to the skin’s
surface increases, making your skin a lot
warmer, and sometimes more sweaty.
These two factors may result in you being
more attractive to mosquitoes, at least as
far as this commonly touted hypothesis goes.
That said, in one study looking at the effects
of alcohol consumption on mosquito attractiveness,
Alcohol Ingestion Stimulates Mosquito Attraction,
while, as the title of the paper suggests,
they did find alcohol consumption significantly
increased one’s chances of getting bitten
by mosquitoes, contrary to prevailing wisdom,
they found “ethanol content in sweat and
skin temperature did not show any correlation
between alcohol ingestion and mosquito landings.”
It should be noted though that this particular
study was performed using an exceptionally
small sample size of only 13 individuals.
But the bottom line with this one is that
several studies indicate that alcohol consumption
very much does appear to increase the likelihood
of being bitten by mosquitoes, but, as with
so many of the known attractants, exactly
why this is the case is still a matter of
debate.
Pregnant women are also more attractive to
mosquitoes (statistically almost twice as
likely to be bitten than the rest of the general
populace).
The culprits in this case are generally thought
to mirror those of exercisers: carbon dioxide
and heat.
Pregnant women exhale on average about 21%
more carbon dioxide than when they are not
pregnant.
Their body temperature is also typically slightly
higher than non-pregnant individuals, particularly
around the belly.
Another factor that potentially attracts mosquitoes
from afar is clothing color and movement.
While it’s not completely understood why
mosquitoes are more attracted to people wearing
darker colored clothing, the general hypotheses
put forth are that it may have something to
do with making you stand out more on the horizon
(mosquitoes tend to fly low to the ground
to stay out of the wind as much as possible)
and it may also have something to do with
heat, with dark clothing absorbing more sunlight.
Moving around is presumed to make you more
attractive to mosquitoes via motion allowing
the mosquito to better distinguish your body
from the surrounding environment.
So that’s the initial attraction.
Just because a mosquito is attracted to you
from afar, once they get close up (and even
after they land), they may actually decide
not to bite.
After all, an idling car gives off plenty
of carbon dioxide and heat, which will initially
attract a mosquito, but once up close, the
lack of other markers will let it know it’s
not a potential blood source.
The factors involved in whether a mosquito
will decide to land and then whether they
decide to bite essentially comes down to your
general scent and then taste, both in terms
of certain chemicals attracting the mosquito
even more and others potentially repelling
them.
How sweaty you are at a given moment, and
what exactly is in your sweat, will greatly
influence these attractive and repellent factors,
with such markers as lactic acid, uric acid,
and ammonia being among the compounds in your
sweat and other skin excretions that attract
mosquitoes.
On the other hand, those who naturally excrete
the compound 6-methyl-5-hepten-2-one have
been found to be significantly less likely
to be bitten owing to this compound acting
as something of a mosquito repellent.
One’s blood type also seems to be one of
the markers used by mosquitoes to determine
whether you’re a good candidate for a blood
meal.
How?
Approximately 85% of people emit certain blood
type markers, something at least certain types
of mosquitoes seem to be able to detect.
While significantly more research needs done
to determine whether blood type really makes
that much of a difference in likelihood of
being bitten by a mosquito, in one study looking
at Asian Tiger Mosquitoes, it was found that
people with Type O blood were nearly twice
as likely to be bitten as people with type
A blood.
(If you’re curious, see What is the Difference
Between Blood Types? and Why Can’t You Use
the Blood from People Who Have a Different
Blood Type Than You?)
It also appears that the blend of microbes
living on your body also effects how attractive
you are to at least certain types of mosquitoes,
although research into this is also pretty
scant at this stage.
That said, in one 2011 study, Composition
of Human Skin Microbiota Affects Attractiveness
to Malaria Mosquitoes, they found that more
diverse colonies of microbes on your skin
actually seems to repel mosquitoes, whereas
a high density of just a small number of certain
microbes, such as Staphylococcus spp, seems
to attract them.
Beyond certain people actually being more
attractive to female mosquitoes than others,
there’s also the fact that some people are
more reactive to mosquito bites.
After the mosquito has drunk her fill of your
blood, she leaves behind the cocktail that
is her saliva.
Your body’s response to this foreign substance
is to produce a variety of antibodies to bind
to the antigens in the saliva, which in turn
releases the nitrogen compound histamine.
Why this is a good thing most of the time
is that histamine helps your white blood cells
and other proteins engage whatever is invading
your body by making the capillaries of these
cells more permeable.
The downside in the case of mosquito bites
is that this triggers an inflammatory response
causing the bite region to swell into a nice
pink bump.
If you scratch this bump, this irritates and
inflames the area even more, resulting in
your immune system kicking into overdrive
to try to get rid of the foreign substance.
So this means more inflammation for you, resulting
in an ever swelling, itchy bump that just
won’t go away.
For some, their body’s histamine response
is minimal, meaning they may not even be aware
they were just a blood meal for a mosquito.
For others, every bite becomes swollen and
itchy.
So if one person’s body doesn’t really
react much, or at all, to a mosquito’s bite,
that person may think they’re one who isn’t
very attractive to mosquitoes even though
they may be, and vice versa.